avec nous Eric Girard ministre des
Finances bonsoir Monsieur Gérard bonsoir
content de poursuivre votre travail au
finance oui c'est un honneur de servir
et je suis très content de mes
responsabilités encore une fois là c'est
une équipe économique importante que
monsieur Legault a constitué comment
vous voyez votre rôle Monsieur Girard ou
côté de Monsieur
tous les fronts là pour soutenir la
croissance par rapport à toutes les
priorités à ces coûteuses de votre
gouvernement aussi santé éducation
développement durable également il y en
a beaucoup à faire mais on travaille
toujours en équipe c'est certain et puis
on a un but commun qui est de propulser
le Québec à un autre niveau et le plan
de match est clair on travaille sur la
main d'oeuvre on travaille sur la
productivité des entreprises des
infrastructures publiques les
investissements l'innovation et
notre plan de match il est connu il y a
du fiscal il y a de l'aide directe du
Conseil alors on va continuer ce plan de
match là qui fonctionne bon les Finances
du Québec sont quand même dans un état
enviable par rapport à d'autres
provinces ou d'autres États mais on peut
pas tout faire non plus est-ce que ça
vous met ça en tant que ministre des
Finances dans une position d'être celui
qui va devoir dire non qui va devoir
parfois freiner les ardeurs de tous ceux
qui aimeraient bien beaucoup dépenser et
aller de l'avant avec leur priorités
j'ai 4 ans d'expérience dans ce poste
puis je pourrais vous dire que la chose
plus facile à faire c'est de dire non ce
qui est vraiment un défi c'est de
trouver une façon d'aider mes collègues
à réaliser leurs ambitions nos ambitions
et on travaille toujours ensemble et
dans le passé on a montré qu'on
réalisait ce que nous promettions et on
va continuer puis là on a des mesures
pour aider les Québécois à faire face à
la hausse du coût de la vie viendront
des mesures plus structurantes comme les
baisses d'impôts pour stimuler l'offre
de travail la création de richesse
chaque chose en son temps oui
avec des défis quand même parce que le
risque d'une récession a peut-être
augmenté depuis même depuis le rapport
pré électoral qui a été présenté il y a
pas si longtemps et toute la semaine on
entendait à Ottawa dire ben on va aider
les gens mais de manière beaucoup plus
chirurgicale parce que
c'est fini le temps du bar ouvert si
vous voulez vous avec vos mesures par
exemple le chèque vous allez quand même
aider 6 millions 400 000 Québécois
est-ce que ce sera plus réduit par la
suite si la récession devait se
concrétiser mais encore une fois c'est
un
bouclier une panoplie de mesure c'est à
dire que le montant de 600 dollars pour
ceux qui gagnent moins de 54000 et 400
dollars pour ceux qui gagnent 54000 si
pour aider immédiatement à faire face à
la hausse du coup de la vie les tarifs
que nous voulons niveler un maximum de
3% c'est également pour s'assurer en
fait ça va aider à baisser l'inflation
de mettre un plafond sur les tarifs
c'est pour aider encore une fois lutter
contre la hausse
c'est lorsqu'on va vouloir stimuler la
création de richesse l'offre de travail
mais là c'est des baisses d'impôts c'est
pour ceux qui paient des impôts
évidemment et qui ont des revenus de
travail qui les amènent au dessus du
seuil minimum où on doit payer de
l'impôt mais c'est on parle ici de 4.6
millions de personnes qui payent des
impôts au Québec cela dit quel est votre
lecture à vous le concernant la
progression de l'économie quels sont vos
estimations face aux risques d'une
récession est-ce que ça augmente et quel
impact ça pourrait avoir sur les
finances publiques en fait ce qu'on a au
niveau de l'impact la sensibilité des
finances publiques on a toujours dit
c'est à 1% de croissance c'est à peu
près 1 milliard de
d'impact sur les finances publiques sur
une base annuelle alors ça c'est le la
sensibilité de l'économie au choc des
finances publiques un choc l'économie
c'est à peu près un pour un
au niveau de ce qui s'est passé depuis
le rapport prélectoral c'est que les
banques centrales ont décidé d'être plus
agressives notamment la Réserve fédérale
américaine qui a bougé
l'estimation du taux terminal de ce
cycle aussi de tout alors avant
lors du rapport électoral notamment on
croyait qu'autour de 3 et 3 3 4%, ça
allait suffisant 4% de tempérer
l'économie et là on parle de 4-3/4 alors
il y a eu ce réajustement des
anticipations de hausse de tout qui a
amené une correction des marchés
boursiers et tout ça ralentit l'économie
et augmente la probabilité de la session
alors pratiquons pratique pour le Québec
nous avions une prédiction de 3.4% pour
2022 un point 7 % pour 2023 si certains
que lorsque nous allons publier la mise
à jour quelque part en novembre
descendre la mise à jour budgétaire et
économique du Québec on va réviser ces
chiffres là à la main bon je vous emmène
sur un autre terrain en terminant
monsieur Gérard François Legault qui
semble avoir entendu l'avertissement de
la PDG d'Hydro-Québec le sophie Brochu
la semaine dernière alors il annonce
aussi la création d'un comité sur
l'économie la transition énergétique
dont elle fera partie on va te compagnie
d'ailleurs et d'autres ministres quel
sera le mandat de ce comité
c'est une bonne question c'est on
travaille toujours en équipe le
ministère des Finances et toujours
impliqué dans les dossiers qui
nécessitent des qui ont des impacts sur
le cadre financier du gouvernement alors
on a une quantité limitée d'énergie à ça
s'ajoutera ce qu'on peut faire au niveau
de l'économie de l'énergie au niveau des
des énergies renouvelables les éoliennes
et éventuellement peut-être des projets
de nouvelles ouvrages de production
alors l'idée c'est de bien gérer notre
patrimoine ce qu'on a de capacité
d'hydroélectricité et de bien l'alouer
pour avoir un impact maximum dans
l'économie et la transition énergétique
et écologique très bien merci beaucoup
Monsieur Gérard
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]